hi Tom McShea here alongside carolyn
pedak hello we're gonna look at some
footage of Mario Kart 8
yes so this game is coming out in May I
know not me can't get here soon enough
it's really far because you had a chance
to play it and I did it yeah and you did
too and it all it feels so good this
game just feels so good to play and it's
so gorgeous to look at you know seeing
these characters and these tracks in HD
really doesn't make a huge difference
yes Mario Kart 8 we both played it Tom
yes I think we both agree it's it's
pretty neat yeah well I mean the big
thing about Mario Kart is of course the
controls yes and this game feels
incredibly tight like I want and the
boots you get for power sliding AHA does
not require sneaking that's definitely a
plus
yeah it is just like you pick it up and
you're like oh yeah
this is why I love Mario Kart Frank it
just feels intuitive and great and of
course do you mean the other side of
what makes Mario Kart games great I
think is is great track design and
they're definitely doing some really
exciting things in one four eight with
the track design yeah they they go a
little they say screw gravity basically
yeah and I guess we're seeing that here
is like you just you go up the side
walls and you go upside down yeah there
were times where it's it's kind of
wonderfully disorienting because I'm I'm
just focused on the road in front of me
and so I think I'm just kind of level
with the ground and then I look up and I
see that oh my god I'm like
perpendicular to to the surface that I
started on you know you just get these
kind of wonderful sort of
vertigo-inducing disorienting situations
where where the geometry of the track
just kind of blows your mind as you can
see here there's some really different
types of vehicles in this in Mario Kart
right these like futuristic hovercrafts
no not anything that we've seen before
this game does still have borrowing from
like Mario Kart 7 it has the gliding it
has some underwater sections but it also
has that's true for every vehicle but
there's also just carts right and
motorcycles and ATVs
and three-wheeled vehicles I don't
remember what those are called also the
seven Koopaling are all in this thank
goodness thank goodness every last one
of them is in here can you name all
seven ah there's there's Ludwig there's
a would the Nintendo roughly showing
this one of them said Ron right like
five minutes later like oh no wait it's
Roy yeah so they're not as kind of cool
having just I suppose a bunch of
different here can he do yeah yeah I
think I personally would have rather
instead of seven buildings seven other
you know more buried characters from
throughout the kind of Mario universe
might have been maybe a little Super
Mario Brothers to love with where are we
yes i mouse are we ever gonna see those
characters again warg is like we get shy
good we do but shy guys I got shows up
now in like all kinds of mainstream
Mario games oh wow oh yeah the CBS
television shows built on shy guy very
mainstream well I guess that's it for
our look at Mario Kart 8 thanks for
joining us stay tuned again for more
coverage of Mario Kart 8 in the near
future